schools closed for months all because of
the pandemic kids forced to stay at home
and it's usually the mothers who are
left to deal with the added burden I
usually have one hour in my calendar
block for lunch and you have to do
grocery shopping cooking eating cleaning
up and checking homework in one hour
that's just impossible
as the world struggles with Cova 19 some
women fear that it's pushing them back
into traditional roles the pandemic has
a setback for women will speak with an
expert in just a moment but first let's
look at the story of one woman forced to
put a pause on her career after the
local schools closed watercolors instead
of spreadsheets normally and amante
would be sitting in the office right now
but with schools and nurseries closed
due to the pandemic and her husband at
work she has to stay at home something
she never wanted dad it's do stunts this
is a standstill and it is based on the
fact that as a woman I said I'll step
back I'll put my own needs on a whole
and yes that feels like I'm in a type of
role right now that doesn't really fit
me I must I need to be past being a good
housewife was never honest intention she
had just finished a master's in
education when the crisis hit she
postponed finding a job to cater for the
family now pancakes often on the menu
one of the few things she knows how to
cook but even that can get stressful but
can't align and charge you can't decide
anything on your own
you're always together two three four
other people there's not a minute of
rest and you can imagine what that does
to you as a person when you're
constantly under pressure constantly
caring for someone else
permanent doctors or a permanent no
we've burned them because we took too
much anti Osmos explains that the
coronavirus crisis forces women back
into old gender roles acid Adhan billing
research shows there is a backward
development
and partnerships 26 percent of women
have reduced their working hours to
organize childcare in the coronavirus
crisis but only 16 percent of men have
done so damina the end of a long day for
Ana's husband Constantine before the
crisis he and his wife were both working
and taking care of the kids now he's
suddenly the classic working dad which
is not to his taste either it's not that
easy
I simply earn more for that well
hopefully it changed that one day I
won't have to work full-time but that's
in the future and I think that our
society still promotes gender
stereotypes that are no longer
appropriate and that doesn't recognize
the fact that fathers want to be with
their children I'm Popeye Dickens and
Constantine oh they'll have to negotiate
this fragile balance until for once
schools reopen they hope to get back to
a life with more self-determination for
both of them and I'm joined now by
Johanna make Huck
she's secretary-general of the European
women's Lobby and that's an umbrella
group of women's advocacy or
associations rather in Europe and she
joins me from Brussels welcome Joanna
now we know that the pandemic has
uprooted many families and workers why
is it that women are carrying such an
especially heavy load well women are
actually the backbone of our societies
and they already carry a very heavy load
and what this pandemic has done is
actually shone a light on and in some
cases exacerbated what were already very
deep-rooted
inequalities between women and men in
Europe in fact we've actually stopped
progressing on gender equality on
equality between women and men in Europe
we've stopped progressing for 10 years
already
so there was a great deal to do to
really start to fast forward and
fast-track equality between women and
men
and certainly this this pandemic we've
seen families really challenged and
particularly women bearing the brunt of
childcare of stepping back from their
jobs of going part-time of being made
redundant over
well mainly women have taken on that
burden but what we know already is that
women already do the vast majority of
childcare and unpaid care work a
domestic work in Europe still today and
that's hardly shifted in the last
generation now we saw a report earlier
about an in Germany stepping back to
take care of her kids during the
pandemic can we say that things will go
back to normal for her once the schools
and daycare centres reopen yeah I think
that story is very very difficult for
millions and millions of women and
millions of families across Europe we're
really what we see already is that it's
gonna be a political choice what happens
next and the choices that our leaders
make right now about the kind of society
we want to build post this pandemic the
kind of values we want to put at the
center of that society are going to be
really important with the financial
crisis in 2008 what we saw was that with
the response the political choice to
pursue austerity was really done at
there at the cost of women it was done
on the backs of women in fact we saw
that women paid around 75 percent of
their of the costs of the cuts to public
services through cutbacks to their jobs
through cutbacks to check care
infrastructure which impacted on women's
labor market participation so we need to
learn from those the mistakes we made
then and make sure that now as we as
leaders make choices about the kind of
society we want to rebuild after this
pandemic that the issues of inequality
between women and men are put center
stage in the analysis in the policies
that are put in place and in terms of
the budgets that are put in place and in
particular the emphasis on care what
gives me hope is that actually this
pandemic has brought into a public
conversation the issues about who's
doing the care how do we want the care
infrastructure to look how do you want
to care for our children for our older
people for each other and and who is
gonna be doing that so that means we
need a really bold new care deal for
Europe and Joanna briefly if you can are
you seeing in the recovery packages that
are being laid out right now by
individual nations do you see some of
these policies being put in there that
you want to see advanced we've seen in
the response to the pandemic some really
good measures but
keely when it comes to addressing
violence against women which we've also
seen increased during the pandemic and
we've seen a more political conversation
about care elder care child care and
care for disabled persons and the
disproportionate impact on women but
when it comes to the actual response and
when it comes to the money which is
where we see how the how the policy is
translated into action we absolutely
have not seen enough we need to see
really
at least half of the resources for the
recovery package going to women so we're
calling for half the money at least to
go to two measures which address the
inequalities between women and men so
know not enough is being done yet all
right we're gonna have to leave it there
Joana macaque with the European women's
Lobby in Brussels thank you very much
thank you it's time now to answer your
questions about Coppa 19 over to our
science correspondent Derek Williams I
read that the virus might have arrived
in Europe by early November is there
evidence it was around earlier than in
China at the end of December the working
thesis has always been that the first
kovat 19 infections occurred at a wet
market in Wuhan back in early December
but but there's been a lot of suspicion
over over whether that's really the
whole story especially since a new study
that looked at how the virus has evolved
said it might have emerged as early as
October then another a heavily contested
report from from Harvard researchers
which hasn't been peer reviewed yet
recently also made a splash it looked at
among other things satellite images of
parking lots in Wuhan hospitals and it
says visitors to them surged as early as
last August though the authors admitted
that their evidence was not an airtight
argument for for pushing back the
origins of the pandemic so while there
are some claims the outbreak began long
before the first official cases appeared
and in Wuhan they're still only
supported by by disputed data his
Germany also were
a vaccine for covet 19 this question
came in a few weeks ago but now seems
like it's the right time to answer it
since the German government just
announced that it was sinking 300
million euros into a German biotech
company called cure vac you might
remember that that's the firm that that
Donald Trump allegedly tried to lure to
the u.s. back in March its vaccine
platform which uses what's called
messenger RNA to provoke an immune
response it is currently in testing in
animal models and the and the company
says results so far are very promising a
rival German firm called by on tech has
also teamed up with with us-based
company Pfizer in in pursuit of the same
goal but it hasn't received any funding
from the German government I see people
jogging and cycling wearing masks is
that medically advisable first of all I
can tell you from from from personal
experience that jogging with a mask is
no fun at all it gets it gets really hot
it gets really humid and and it
seriously affects your performance that
said if you are infectious it'll
probably make you less of a danger to
the to the people around you experts now
widely accept that the virus is
transmitted as an aerosol so so
theoretically at least an infected
person panting along in the park is is
giving off clouds of floating infectious
droplets on the other hand almost all of
our solid information on aerosol
distribution comes from enclosed spaces
what we do know is that is that outdoor
transmission of the virus appears to be
very rare so long and short like pretty
much everyone else here in Berlin
I stopped jogging with a mask pretty
quickly even though there's no real
scientific consensus on it and finally a
feast for the eyes
thanks to pandemic measures wildlife is
reclaiming the tourist free kalapa goose
islands located a thousand kilometers
off the coast of Ecuador sea lions
iguanas a mini bird species are now
moving freely on the archipelago which
has been under lockdown for more than
two months scientists studying the
impact of tourism say a number of key
species have returned since travel was
halted and they'll compare their
observations to measurements taken once
tourists returned